[Music]
today's question comes from jill in
mississippi she says i'd like to hear
your opinion on an engaged christian
couple asking for donations via gofundme
to help them pay off the groom's debts
so they can start their marriage
debt-free
well i've heard it all dave that's an
interesting one
gofundme which if you don't know is a
fundraising platform online you can set
up for pretty much any need and people
can donate you can set your goal and you
get to keep all the money even if you
don't hit the goal with gofundme
so for an engaged christian couple
asking for donations to get this groom
debt free i love the heart behind it i
love that he wants to become debt free
that's about where i stop liking this
picture
it
you know what makes it feel weird is
just the gofundme part
that's the only thing that makes it
because listen if they just call if they
just said hey uh in lieu of wedding
gifts we'd like cash to pay off our debt
you wouldn't think that was weird no i
mean you would go that's oh well you
it's weird it's different but i mean you
wouldn't most people want to get
yourself that wouldn't be a turn off
but for some reason it's a turn off and
this woman thinks it is because she has
to throw in that they're christians
which has nothing to do with this
what is what is what i don't know where
that came gofundme is not in the bible i
mean i don't what is that
they're an engaged christian couple
which
i'm reading between the lines this this
person doesn't think this is proper
she's trying to say it's not christian
it has nothing to do with the faith look
instead of wedding gifts they wanted
cash
that doesn't turn me off but when you go
go find me it's kind of because i'm an
old geezer i just i'd immediately go
yeah
but that's just a modern way of getting
cash instead of
it's a technological way of getting cash
when you take the wedding part out of it
it's like the cash have to venmo oh give
me a break but okay but
right um
there's no real need here now if they
were in turmoil there was a health issue
it's a little bit different but just the
fact that you're getting married doesn't
make me go well we should definitely pay
junior's credit cards off yeah but if i
mean when you get married you get a
whole bunch of crap
as gifts that you're never going to use
i'd rather have the cash personally and
get the debt paid off
i don't think it's tacky but that's me i
don't have any couth so i have no man
i don't know which side the fork goes on
okay so what do i know but coming from a
modern millennial we had our normal gift
registry but we also had a house down
payment fund because we were why is that
not as tacky as this because it was just
a thing if you wanted to support that
instead of buying us a spatula you could
do that but it wasn't asking me to pay
off the debt before the wedding via
gofundme that had nothing to do with the
wedding so it feels separate
i don't even know if anyone did it it
was just a fun thing we decided you know
this is what we're passionate about and
we're gonna put it on there in case
family and friends yeah the question
actually i'm reading into it it does not
say this is instead of a wedding gift
it just starts it just says make
donations now that's different from
people who may not even be at the
wedding yeah that's different too no i'm
not gonna give somebody but in lieu of a
wedding gift if they would rather have
cash because they are trying to buy a
house
like george i would be cool with that
i'd rather have a house than a cake
knife
and that's the problem you go to target
and you start scanning things
willy-nilly because you think every
couple needs the cake stand stop buying
the cake stand millennials what are you
doing with the cake stand it's well and
worse than target home depot oh that's
dangerous for the game just give george
tools that he doesn't even know what
they do well now they have the fancy
battery ones so i get more excited about
that i know but you don't still don't
know what they do they're just for
battery okay
fair point so but i mean yeah that's you
could get you could get a bunch of crap
in our culture and money actually
translates so i don't know um
jill obviously thinks it's tacky and i
can tell that because she throws the
christian thing in there so i'm just
saying but
um
i if it was a in lieu of a wedding gift
and it was cash it wouldn't feel as
weird but because we're not sure it's a
wedding gift and because go you through
gofundme in there like you're some kind
of a charity
uh that's the part that makes it because
gofundme is almost usually for need well
someone
lost their house in a fire
medical bills because they got cancer or
something like that right and that's
usually the stuff go fund me just
getting married and you got some debt i
want to buy a new car i've got to go
fund me would you help me you know
people do that stuff there's some
goobers have it on there for paying off
their student loans and stuff and
people we see that stuff pop up but
that's all weird and maybe that's what's
weird about it i don't know well note to
self dave's not going to support my
gofundme so i won't ask no i really
won't i might give you some money but
it'd just be i'm not running through
that i'll take hey whatever you got i'll
take it yeah well
i've got a battery operated sawzall i'll
just tell you that